In the face of immortality, morality is going
to radically change, right.
We’ve evolved to die.
Like for the entire history of life on this
planet life has come to an end.
There is nothing, you know, consciously there’s
nothing period out there that says this is
how you behave if you live forever.
This is how you start to structure a society
if I can store my personality on a computer.
This is what I do.
I can store that personality onto a computer
and download it into another body.
These are huge, far flung really strange questions,
right.
And they seem totally science fiction at this
point but everything we’ve seen over the
past 25 years, right, is most of the science
fiction cannon from the twentith century has
turned into science fact in the twenty-first
century already.
So this twenty-first century sci-fi idea of
mind uploading is probably going to be here
by the twenty-second century.
So we’ve got 50 years, 70 years to start
figuring out these really complicated hard
questions.
The idea in mind uploading is that we can
store ourselves on silicon.
We can upload our personalities, our brains,
some part of our consciousness onto computers
and they can stay around forever.
It is a far out there technology for sure
even though British Telecom is working on
it, even though people are working on it.
It’s very early days.
Ray Kurzweil has famously kind of pegged the
date when we’re going to have to deal with
this problem as 2045.
That may be really, really enthusiastic.
I think it’s a conservative prediction.
But the point is that at some point in the
century this is probably going to get real.
And you’ve got to stop and you’ve got
to go for all five of the world’s major
religions just to start there.
Use the threat of the hereafter, right.
What’s going to happen after this life to
steer morality and shape behavior.
So what happens to theological morality in
the face of technological immortality is the
big kind of metaphysical question.
If you look at the science fiction work of
Richard K. Morgan whose fantastic, he talks
about what happens when consciousness becomes
downloadable and bodies become expendable
and what that means for soldiers and armies
and mercenaries and things along those lines.
So there’s a really like a gritty cyberpunk
underbelly in the mind uploading technology
even though it’s being developed for educational
purposes so we can preserve the brains of
the Einstein’s and the Beethoven’s and
the Richard Feynman’s of the world and really
kind of get inside them.
But it’s sort of like I think of it like
television, right.
When they created television they thought
it was going to be used for educational purposes
and that was the only – ask the creator
of TV what do you think this would be good
for.
Well education of course.
Fifty years later there’s not much education.
There’s a whole lot of crap and I think
we can see the same thing with mind uploading.
But the difference of course is that mind
uploading, storing selves on silicon, even
teetering on the edge of so-called immortality
changes everything about what it means to
be human at a really fundamental deep level.
And when I say fundamental deep level I mean
we’re starting to muck around and mess around
with evolutionary processes.
Processes we have no idea what happens if
you interrupt them because we’ve never done
it before.